[Music]
that's travis barker's son landon
modeling in the amiri autumn winter 2022
runway show and cheering from the front
row was his proud papa and fiance
kourtney kardashian
[Music]
[Applause]
court rocked a black coat over a lacy
look pairing it with a black cross
choker and of course her stunning
engagement ring and the couple didn't
shy away from their signature pda in
front of the cameras i love it also
there in support the push founder's son
mason disick as well as travis's
daughter alabama and his step-daughter
atiana de la hoya and there's no doubt
landon's sisters are his biggest fans
[Music]
atiana posted this shot of landon and
gushed sorry for making you laugh i'm so
proud of you yup the 18 year old
couldn't help but smile after landon's
big night the entire fam hit ellie hot
spot craigs for a celebratory dinner
and it looks like we might get to see
some bts of the fashion show on courtney
and her famous fam's new reality show
the kardashians
you have no idea what's coming
are you ready the kardashians
the mom of three shared this pic on
instagram it's her mic pack laying next
to the outfit she wore
and seeing travis on the hulu series
should come as no surprise last june a
source told et the blink 182 drummer is
expected to make an appearance his kids
may appear as well but not as much as he
will be featured i'm just like living
life and
whatever happens happens but if it's up
to court's sister kim we'll be seeing
lots of the rocker on the show i'm
assuming because he's such a big part of
courtney's life that hopefully they will
be on i love their relationship like
they've
grown so much together and have really
like made some amazing um just i mean to
think that they've been neighbors and
friends for almost 15 years neighbors
for like a decade and then all of a
sudden
they cannot keep their hands off of each
other i mean like
and all that love and affection turned
into an engagement travis popped the
question in october proposing a court on
the beach in front of a lavish floral
display
i love you
and we know we'll see that romantic
moment on the kardashians mama 3
confirmed it when she shared a sneak
peek at the footage on her instagram
story
[Music]